poire la menace planait sur le tour
depuis son retour en france chacun se
demandait quand les responsables de
l'équipe festina serait entendu par les
policiers du srpj de lille une
perspective qui s'était encore renforcé
quand le soigneur de l'équipe festina
arrêté à la frontière belge avec un
grand nombre de produits dopants avait
affirmé agir à la demande de ses
dirigeants
ce soir c'est donc chose faite bruno
roussel le directeur sportif ainsi que
le médecin de l'équipe ont été emmenés
par les policiers dès l'arrivée de la 4e
étape pour être placé en garde à vue au
commissariat de cholet
l' enquête sur place d'olivier galzi et
de françois prix là
comment réagissez-vous essentiel la
police ne les laissera pas s'exprimer
abassourdi brune rousse elle a tout
juste le temps de prendre un pull le
directeur sportif de l'équipe festina
vient d'être interpellé à quelques
dizaines de mètres à peine de la ligne
d'arrivée une opération discrète malgré
la foule menées par les enquêteurs
venu directement de lille comment
réagissent évolution saine l'attendiez
alors oui nous y voilà mais bruno
roussel s'attendaient à une simple
audition
or il est placé en garde à vue une garde
à vue qui pourrait durer quatre jours
deux minutes à peine après avoir déposé
bruno roussel au commissariat de cholet
le srpj de lille repart en opération
cette fois ci c'est une perquisition à
l'hôtel de l'équipe festina dans un
camion en saisissent une mallette
médical qu'ils iront ouvrir à
l'intérieur de l'hôtel à l'abri des
regards indiscrets
ce soir à cholet on ne parlait pas du
vainqueur de l'étape le tour de france
est sous le choc